The
toxic.
I'm Kevin Valcon. We're here with the
suicide squad cast, so let's welcome them.
Yeah.
Are you guys
the real versions in the mini
versions of you guys? Cool.
A huge blockbuster hit coming up this
summer for you guys on August 5th so thank
you guys all for being here.
David, this is your movie.
I'm just absolutely
phenomenal. And you know, it's,
it's essentially a film about a villains
brought out of Arkham asylum and jails,
all orchestrated by Ed Amanda
Waller played by Viola Davis.
And she gets pretty during the film.
But so people were going crazy with this,
with comicon and it's, you described
this movie as bad versus evil,
which is really interesting.
So you need to talk about just what's
the difference between bad and evil,
bad and evil. Uh, you know,
the thing about evil, it's
like a, it's like pornography.
You know it when you see it
like, oh yeah, that's a
ass dad is definitely,
but at the end of the day,
look, it's, it's, yeah, sure,
these are the bad guys, but
I think could flashback. That's a good
way to start. That's a good way to start.
Yeah, finally. Right?
No, no. Look, at the end of the day,
it's, you have a group of a bad guys.
He's a super villains,
right?
But they do have good hearts and maybe
they don't know that about themselves in
the beginning,
but along the way they discover that
and they actually see the good in each
other,
formed this incredible family,
and then go on to do some wonderful
things together and you know,
maybe save the world in the process.
Awesome.
And so will you play dead shot,
big popular villain and Batman's know
gallery? Why did you choose dead shot?
So it would, they probably had your
choice of superheroes, I would imagine,
or villains. And so why did you
choose this role over any other?
Uh, actually I didn't, it was
mighty
awkward.
No, Dave came in, he pitched everything.
I loved the character of
Diablo. I was like, Yo,
that's crazy. And Dave was
like, dude, you did shot.
Yeah.
Oh, okay. Okay. Uh, you know,
but really we all, we all see everybody
signed on without a script, right?
Nobody knows. So there
was no script. You know,
I had just seen fury and I knew David's
work and he came and pitched the idea.
And really as a, as a testament
to David, we all signed on with,
with without a screenplay.
He pretty much laid out the characters
that he saw for us in, in his mind.
And we all signed on.
It became a family with
like sort of a kind of a,
a, a loving, uh, malicious abuse,
abusive father,
right?
Yeah.
Normal family
and Margo, you play a Harley Quinn,
so it is absolutely phenomenal.
You nailed the character. Um, it's, it's,
she's really insane and you get to see
the origin story of Harley Quinzel and
it's, it's really, really just
amazing how that's done the film.
But what was the toughest part about
getting her writes about? Just saying, oh,
I found her,
uh, I mean the physical training and
stuff started six months before we started
shooting.
So that stuff was more mechanical and I
knew it was something I could learn if I
put in the hours. The hard part was, um,
finding the vulnerable side
and not being scared to like,
I mean the rehearsal process.
I'm sure you guys have heard David has
a pretty rigorous rehearsal process that
everyone has to be involved in and,
and it's super painful, but um, that,
that side of it was tricky.
And also trying to figure out
the dynamic with the joker.
I just couldn't understand why she was
with him when he tries to kill her all
the time. But it's your voice. The
voice was hard to get to. I didn't, it,
it's hard because the only
portrayal of Holly's voice is super,
super high pitched and
animated and comical.
But when you're doing a David Ayre film,
there's going to be like really deep,
gritty pots as well.
So we needed to find an in between ground.
That's your Jay, uh, your character of El
Diablo. It's without spoiling anything,
the dynamic between you and
will's character of Deadshot
is interesting because
you see in the trailer as well where it's,
he provokes you a lot and you kind of
want to contain your powers it seems like.
And he just wants to bring them out.
Well, there's a, there's a really a,
an important part of the film where,
you know,
his backstory is revealed and he's afraid
to really open that side up because,
uh,
he did something horrific and this,
this new group of people is becoming his
surrogate family and he doesn't want to
destroy them the way he's destroyed
other people. So yeah, it's,
it's interesting to sort of
see that and be revealed, uh,
during the course of the film.
Gotcha.
Okay.
No saying it could be,
is it,
was it just his character is the most
powerful really out of all of us.
And he choose, he doesn't want to
fight. And uh, that, that's, that's,
it's such a beautiful thing. And yet
you haven't seen the movie yet, right?
You guys haven't seen
it. Okay. So yeah, so
I was making sure I was about to do it.
Joel Ketamine show.
Tell him how to tell him how it ends.
Joel is great. It's really good.
This is his, his nickname
is spoiler alert. Well,
Joe will tell any face.
I can't say that I take the mic.
When you were talking about, I was
like, did I say that in the interview?
But I tell him about his backstory.
Gara Gara you play a in Tantra switch,
your character is as scary as hell.
It's crazy. It's, you play
dual roles. It is, it's crazy.
And janitors is absolutely crazy. And uh,
you know, you played archeologists. Yeah.
So he played an archeologist
and then, yeah. And so, um,
but then in chapter it's
like takes over your body.
So we won't reveal how
that happens. But, uh,
what was it like playing just one of
the creepiest villains we've seen? Yeah.
The dates. I don't think she's not
scary. She's just a little daddy.
I'm just saying she needs to go off or
something. Um, I mean, I had a great item,
had such a wonderful time, especially
playing two characters. Um, it was just,
I think the only thing I've found is
difficult was that hair makeup. Every day.
I still have dot. I'll never know how
many hours. Three, three, three. I mean,
I didn't go through as much as
I'd Warlow but it was more the,
the scrubbing at the end of the day,
it was the layers and layers
of blocked up dot. Just fine.
And you guys, you guys had a really good
dynamic on the set, right? Cause it was,
you guys had a group text going on and
was like, suicide, suicide squad for life.
Your suicide squad. Yeah.
It's still going. Yeah. Yeah,
yeah. Well no one's getting
agree to these anytime soon. No.
Oh yeah. And Tattoos. Yeah.
So it's tattoos, Dave. Oh,
he got the squad? Yeah. Joel,
show them yours. Joel has this biggest
one. The biggest one will did that one.
I did that. Why did that
one huge, huge mistake.
Yeah.
We're asking wheel. So when
are you getting your rank?
And he's like, oh, tomorrow,
tomorrow, tomorrow, tomorrow again
at rap rap. Yeah. Rap. Yeah. I don't
want to get it. Why are we shooting?
But Margo brought the gun though that
you didn't you bring the Tattoo Gun. Oh,
let's do it. No, no, no,
no. This is the problem. This
is the, I say all the time,
this is the problem with 40 year olds.
Hang with 20 year olds. It goes wrong.
It goes wrong and it ends in the hospital.
But it wasn't so bad cause you did Joel's
cause I think Joel you asked for the
Tattoo.
Well we were all going to get them and
then I was like yeah we'll do mine.
And then when he started I was like
what the, what's up? Thank you.
Can you describe it as like watching a
drunk baby fly helicopters were exact
descriptions of that. So yeah, I
didn't want to, I didn't want to do it,
but everybody was so excited. You
know, I got wrapped up in a moment.
I'll do it, I'll do a joke. And
that energy that he had right there,
that was the energy he
had while he was tattooing
crazy stuff that happened
on set year. You're shaving
off people's eyebrows. Yeah.
Margot's and you're helping shave at
gyse beard. Jumping off Karen's Harris.
So what, what does that with
your, your process is amazing,
I think is all this stuff that was coming
out of this set of how you get inside
people's heads.
So where did that develop?
What like did you start with that when
you first started filmmaking or did you
okay. In the Navy I did
cut hair in the navy,
you know, I cut hair on the submarine. So,
you know, I've, I've used clippers before,
but it's part of the process. It's, it's
like a, you grab someone out of rehearsal,
you know, alter their
look, throw him back in.
It's a little bit like being in
prison I guess. And uh, you know,
they get mocked by the other prisoners, so
it just helps, uh, helps them get there.
We're in the rehearsal
space and he left with Karen
and came back with her scalp.
He walked in with like the hair. It
was like, oh my God, it's a garden.
We it to Margo.
And she didn't like that Karen,
his hair was midway down her back,
you know,
and it was beautiful and we're like, Oh
wow, it's beautiful David. Say, dude,
come here, clip, clip, and just
cut her hair off. I was like, Yep.
Ah,
and all I could do with this.
Take a picture of it on the floor.
Okay.
Post this Karen.
You play, get them boomerang. And,
which is probably one of the
funniest parts of the film.
He's the most hinged on hinge character.
So can you talk about just developing
that character in his, his crazy psyche?
Uh, yeah, I had to go
pretty, pretty crazy.
A undergo a pretty crazy trends, uh,
transformation to a, to find him.
It's a stretch. I'm obviously
nothing like the character. Um,
keep it together at all times. Uh, find it
hard to step out of my, out of my shell.
Um, and uh, so it was, it
was pretty intense man.
And uh, it's, it's been
hard to shake off, you know,
what's it been like about 30 years now?
Now here's the thing I like,
I've, I've done movies with,
with actors before. I, you know,
I've had love scenes where, you know,
you use all day long, you're shooting
a love scene with, with someone.
And I've still managed
to see GI naked more.
That was like, dude, just, you
don't just put some clothes on man.
You don't have to, you don't have
to be naked and you're outside.
Do you know you're outside?
We're outside doors.
It's November.
Well it's a damn clothes on.
You got to stay out of base camp,
stairway from the trailer,
stay on sad at safe on set. There's
grownups there. You got to base camp.
Anything could happen.
Yeah.
Well I hear there's a story where you
chase David at the end of the shooting
naked and he just sprinted away from
you at the end of a 20 hour shoot day.
Me, me, me, me and me and Jay,
we were in giant trailer and a,
and Gi was in the shower and um,
and David comes at,
peaks his head and the trailer and
he's like, hey dude, what's going on?
And the Gi comes out of the, out of the
shower and he's only wearing a towel.
And as soon as he sees David,
he just, he drops the towel
and David just instinctively
just like darts out and tag.
I was Diego's second boy and try just
takes off running and he's chasing David
like terminator style,
but make it around the whole studio
parking lot and then is a predator.
You don't run from him.
Instinctual things happen.
It happened when they smell blood. We
have Karen Karen's voice. Like, Hey,
I never got him. I never got him.
Oh, David wanted no parts of it. No.
And I come out, I come out my gym
like what it's going on. No, no GI.
I don't put that on him.
The end game there. What were you going
to do if you did catch him? I, no,
I mean I didn't think about that.
We would have found out when I,
when I get on and David David
told us later, he was like,
I was just trying to find some glass on
the ground that I could run over this
slowing down.
He was barefoot.
Yeah. Now this, this, uh,
this cast was a thoroughly and
perfectly chosen role by role,
uh, perfectly for what, what
are, uh, personalities can, uh,
uh, accurately display on camera.
Yeah, I think it was that pretty,
that was pretty good.
Right. People, right job.
Yeah.
And there's no transitions.
No segue. But Adam, nothing I
can do for that. There's no,
there's no right to quit around
it. So speak. Speaking of penises.
No,
get out of I, there's no way Gary,
keep talk about this. Jesus, the
development of your characters, uh,
just with your training and
got it. Training. The best thing
about it, me and my wife become,
became more bonded because I said Babe,
um, David, uh, called and uh,
he wants me to learn
how to use these ropes
and here we go. Bear rope. Bad
rope. No, we're very much in love.
It brought us closer.
Can I do to tie the knot?
Okay.
Views expressed by the suicide squad
are not necessarily the views of Warner
brothers pictures,
right.
Will Smith.
Well,
Adam was wailing during treating.
Yeah. Air Squat even. Right.
It was embarrassing. Yeah.
They were hard squats,
man. I think Adam, we are,
came in and Jai,
I think Dji,
Margo and Karen were like
the most already in shape.
You know,
like they were in shape.
They hit the set ready and the rest
of us kind of had to get in shape and,
and Adam was, Adam was
like this. Adam was here.
Yeah.
I love this
one. Squat for today. Hey Adam,
what are you squatting?
Gravity man.
Wicked heavy.
Black Day to day.
So Garrett, Garrett,
how about your trading?
Cause I'm guessing it wasn't like that.
Yeah,
well I got trained by Guy Norris,
my stunt double or Molly Ong and Richard
Norton who have worked on Mad Max fury
road. So I got the best
training in the industry. Um,
I didn't have any prior
experience with sword fighting,
but we did a month and a half
of preproduction. I, no, no, no.
It's funny because
in my audition email it said you're
going to do a little bit of martial arts,
some acting, and then if you have
a sword lying around at home,
just bring it just in case. I
was like, who? Who just has one?
But sure enough, I did
have a friend, yeah.
With this, this is Karen's first movie.
She's, this is the first movie she, Yep.
Yeah.
Pretty, pretty much all downhill
from here. Starting from the bottom.
Well, you're phenomenal at
getting down to get down to, um,
so I want to go to go around and what
are your character's greatest weakness or
weaknesses? So we'll start with you.
Well, you could actually, David,
if you could do Jareds because he's
not here for Jared Leto for the joker.
But let's start with you. But your
greatest weakness, your character,
a character's greatest weakness.
Well,
what's interesting about dead shot is he
looks at his love for his daughter as a
weakness, which is really interesting
when you talk about, you know, good,
bad and evil, right? So in his mind,
he considers his daughter his
Achilles heel. God, if it,
if I didn't love this girl, I could just
kill people and not feel bad about it.
But I got this chick now I feel
bad when I picked miss this guy.
All right, so it's like, it's
flipped in his mind. What,
what is good and bad and right and wrong?
Um, I'd say June, like
you got to cut it yet
it was an accident,
but it was really cool.
I think so. Yes, I do. I tried to us.
So I'd say June means weakness is probably
the enchantress and the enchantress
is weakness is probably June.
Well, I thought about that. Farm ditzy.
So the joker's weakness is probably a
Harley Quinn and it's definitely a love
hate, uh, you know, relationship.
And I think that he hates study,
loves her and would never admit that he
loves her and he doesn't even know that
he loves her and he doesn't even
know that he's capable of love.
And I don't think any of us are sure
if he, if he even is capable of love.
I want to know David's weakness.
Oh yeah. Not Us, us,
you guys.
Um,
Holly's weakness.
I mean the obvious answer is the joker,
but I think it's actually his self
esteem and that's why the joke is her
weakness.
Okay.
Uh, Diablo, his weakness is
probably his family. Simple as that,
right?
Yeah. I'd go with the same
kind of theme that flags,
weaknesses, uh, is his
love for June or honey,
but that's awesome. But that's
also strength. It's also strength.
Absolutely. Strength. Strength to, it's
like, it's two sides of the same coin.
I think Katana's weakness is
her willingness to, you know,
sacrifice her own life for justice.
Or you know,
for a husband.
Yes.
He was in a sword.
Euler, Jeez, I can't do this.
Yeah,
he's in. He's in, that's the word.
And don't think you just know that.
That's now Adam Guy caught up.
Yeah.
Damn it out. Um, I mean,
this guy over here like
spoilers all the time. I mean,
really,
we all work so hard and then I like
that comes along and just ruins it for
everyone.
I mean,
slipknots is just women. He, he
likes and he likes, time them up,
gets caught looking at women. That's
basically it. No, no, no. Not,
not Adam.
Slipknot to character.
Character. Okay. Um,
women.
Boom. Right? He's got a Bruno, he's
got, got a weakness for plush toys.
Weak at the knees.
Well, a suicide squad is out August
5th, Friday. I'll get spit this week.
It is absolutely phenomenal. We cannot
think guys enough for being here.
Thank you guys so much.
[inaudible].